sommation d'énergie vous avez été hier
encensée pour avoir contribué à
réveiller les consciences mais
aujourd'hui vous êtes vilipendé pour
avoir refusé de voir dans le nucléaire
un danger imminent et je vais tout
simplement vous posez la question avec
ce kinder bueno que je vais ouvrir et
commencé à déguster sur ce plateau quand
je mange ce nom n'a envoyé mais je pense
que là aujourd'hui vous n'avez pas
vraiment lui faire de la pub au kinder
bueno donc on va pas forcément me le
reprocher mais la question c'est est ce
que quand je mange ce kinder bueno ou
quand je donne ce qui me dire oui nos à
mes enfants je suis plus en danger que
si j'habite aux abords d'une centrale
nucléaire en vrai alors la formule à
laquelle vous faites allusion est une
formule que j'ai employé parce que vous
savez que dans le genre d'exercice que
vous proposez de temps en temps il faut
trouver des moyens très bref en temps
parce qu'on n'a pas beaucoup de temps
pour essayer d'illustrer quelque chose
et la formule qui était qui a été
employé dans l'émission c politique
puisque a cessé dimanche soir vous avez
mis saupoudre que dimanche soir alors
que vous étiez interrogé sur les dangers
du nucléaire vous disiez et je vous cite
si les centrales sont dangereux et si on
décide de supprimer tout ce qui est
dangereux alors supprimons tous ce qui
est dangereux les barrages qui provoque
des milliers de morts quand il sait des
usines chimiques des voitures qui
causent des millions de morts par an et
puis finalement les sucreries comme les
kinder bueno voilà ce que vous avez dit
car l'obésité tue beaucoup plus que le
nucléaire trois millions de personnes
par an
et 1,2 million de morts en europe par an
en effet voilà donc c'était une manière
d'illustrer le fait que si on doit
regarder ce qui est ce qui porte
atteinte à notre santé quelle qu'en soit
la cause
eh bien on va pas retrouver le nucléaire
dans les nuisances qui arrive en tête
voilà c'est un fait et je voulais j'ai
joué à illustrer sa et dans le feu de la
discussion j'ai pris cet exemple vous
comprenez que ça ait choqué une partie
notamment des écolos politique qui ne
comprennent pas votre position alors je
vais redire ce que j'ai dit sur le
plateau je ne considère pas que eux
élevés pour les nommer aujourd'hui soit
dépositaire de la sensibilité de la
totalité des gens qui se préoccupent
d'environnement sinon ils feraient pas 4
% aux élections il fait 80% parce que
quand vous demandez aux français
si l'environnement est quelque chose qui
les préoccupent alors des fois on essaye
de classe et ça par rapport au chômage
au pouvoir d'achat et autres trucs de ce
fait un peu tout et impolie éléments et
à la soirée notamment de cet été ont
nivelé la question climatique est une
des premières préoccupations des voilà
vous avez quatre français sur cinq qui
disent oui effectivement c'est quelque
chose qui me préoccupe et sauf erreur de
ma part y a pas quatre français sur cinq
qui ont voté pour monsieur jadot donc si
je faisais je rappelais juste quelque
chose qui est que ce qu'on a coutume
d'appeler aujourd'hui l'écologie
politique par la force des choses ne
représente pas la sensibilité de la
totalité des gens qui se préoccupent
d'environnement mais sur cette question
en particulier du nucléaire évidemment
c'est au coeur des préoccupations depuis
cette rentrée d'abord parce que ça nous
voulons ni réoccupation depuis des
décennies parce que ça a été un sujet
que les médias ont utilisé de manière
récurrente pour cristalliser des
oppositions alors qu'il ya des tas les
médias ou les où les politiques moi je
pense notamment au sol un débat public
c'est un débat qui est dans les médias
où ça c'est un média qui dans les médias
restons sur un débat en particulier un
débat particulièrement regardé et
attentif c'est le débat de la
présidentielle débat la présidentielle
de 2012 entre françois hollande et
nicolas sarkozy c'était l'un des sujets
cruciaux d'opposition entre les deux
nicolas sarkozy reprochant à françois
hollande son engagement à fermer
fessenheim c'est pas les médias qui ont
inventé ce sujet n'ont absolument mais
enfin dans les engagements de françois
hollande sauf erreur de ma part il y
avait 60 donc on a choisi de passer
beaucoup de temps sur celui là alors
c'est un sujet important
particulièrement dans notre pays mais ce
que je veux dire c'est que c'est quand
même un sujet qui est c'est un
marronnier comme on dit dans notre
métier c'est un truc qui revient en
permanence
je vais prendre un autre exemple ya
quelque chose qui est également très
important dans la vie de nos concitoyens
qui s'appelle le pétrole on n'en parle
quasiment jamais dans les médias parlent
des prix de l'essence oui d'accord mais
on en parle quand c'est trop tard donc
mais ça fait maintenant depuis que je
m'intéresse à au sujet de l'énergie
c'est à dire une vingtaine d'années je
sais que il va y avoir un sujet climat
opaque lima sur la quantité de pétrole
dont on peut disposer dans le monde
occidental à partir des années 2005 en
gros ce que ce qui s'est passé est sûre
et dans le monde dans son ensemble aux
alentours des années 2020 ce qui est en
train de se passer ce qui veut dire que
silence radio guerre on les crée or
question de ailleurs question c'est bon
là parce que les gisements s'épuisent
bon parce qu'il faut des dizaines de
millions d'années où des centaines de
millions d'années pour faire du pétrole
et donc quand on consomme s'assure un
siècle ça s'épuise et c'est qu'un un
sujet sur lequel ça a été impossible
globalement et j'ai toujours
raisonnablement impossible d'attirer
l'attention de vos ex confrères de vos
confrères de vos futurs confrères donc
c'est que c'est or c'est un sujet majeur
donc c'est pas juste parce que le sujet
est important il ya une organisation des
débats médiatiques et en particulier dès
qu'on peut mettre des étiquettes pro ou
anti sur la tête des gens c'est quand
même quelque chose dans votre profession
raffolent en règle générale
entre écolos il ya aussi des écoles
c'est à dire que s'ils voudront regarder
si vous regardez le sondage si vous
regardez les sondages par exemple il ya
quelque chose qui m'a beaucoup surpris a
pas très longtemps on avait demandé aux
militants eux élevé justement quel était
leur sensibilité sur le nucléaire c'est
pas homogène ça veut dire qu'il ya des
gens qui votent élevé et qui considèrent
que le cpie l'oreille nucléaire
absolument donc c'est quelque chose
qu'ils essaient comme tous les sujets
techniques c'est des sujets pour
lesquels si on prend pas le temps de
rentrer un peu dans les détails et
d'avoir des avis un peu nuancé on en
ressort avec des écarts il va le faire
jean marc jancovici parce que je trouve
ça justement important d'entendre la
nuance est d'avoir de la place et du
temps pour la nuance vrai qu'on revienne
dans un instant sur la question aussi de
la sobriété ça veut dire quoi dans nos
gestes mais pardon il ya quand même un
danger en tout cas qui est brandi comme
une vraie menace c'est aussi sa peau
ridja c'est aussi la fragilité des
centrales nucléaires est ce que quand
jean-luc mélenchon j'aurais juste qu'on
écoute ces maudits qu'aujourd'hui il ya
un vrai danger est que nucléaire il a
raison ou pas en écoute
il faut cesser de mentir aux français en
le disant que le nucléaire est une
énergie sûre parce qu'elle ne l'est pas
et parce que le danger s'est accrue dès
lors qu'il y à la canicule et la
sécheresse
ce n'est pas vrai que ce soit une
énergie stable au contraire des
éoliennes ou des machines marie motrices
puisque nous avons aujourd'hui 29
centrale sur 58 qui sont arrêtés
autrement dit parce que tous ces gens
viennent de découvrir que le nucléaire
aussi et sur la planète terre sous le
climat de la planète terre et qu'on ne
refroidit pas une centrale avec de l'eau
chaude il faut cesser de mentir aux
français qui ment vous connaissez la loi
de brandolini non alesi la loi de brando
qui vous dit que quand vous avez un
temps égal pour quelqu'un qui a dit
quelque chose d' inexact et quelqu'un
qui essaye d'expliquer pourquoi c'est
inexact la personne qui essaye
d'expliquer pourquoi c'est inexact perd
toujours pas ce qu'il faut dix secondes
pour dire une bêtise il faut en général
plusieurs minutes pour expliquer
pourquoi c'est
alors d'abord il a parlé de porridge à
notre ami mélenchon de là c'était
globalement sera question aussi du
réchauffement climatique puisque l'autre
mais c'est sur la question du
réchauffement climatique en gros une
centrale nucléaire comme toutes les
centrales thermiques est une centrale
qui a besoin d'une source froide c'est
vrai également pour les centrales à
charbon c'est vrai également pour les
centrales à gaz
cette source froide on va aller la
chercher soi dans une rivière soit dans
la mer soit dans l'air quand on va
chercher dans l'air ces grandes tours
vous savez qu'avec nous il ya de la
vapeur l'image d'epinal de la centrale
nucléaire là c'est la grande tour de
réfrigération dans toutes les centrales
en bord de mer dans non programmés et on
va aller chercher donc la source froide
quelque part à partir du moment où vous
avez une diminution du débit dans l'est
dans les fleuves vous avez la
possibilité évidemment vous avez la
possibilité risque plus exactement la
sécheresse de devoir absolument de
devoir ralentir ou baisser la production
d'une centrale nucléaire mais d'une
centrale à charbon ou si
tout simplement parce que vous avez la
possibilité enfin - la possibilité de
refroidir votre centrale et donc vous
devez baisser la production vous pouvez
produire moins de chaleur à l'intérieur
de la centrale il ya pas de peine de
sûreté c'est aussi à ça ça risque pas
ils risquent pas d'avoir un accident le
risque c'est de baisser la production
toutes les centrales thermiques en bord
de fleuve ont exactement le même
problème quand même d'accidents n'y a
pas de risque d'accidents avec le
réchauffement des eaux non sable c'est
pas c'est pas simple de sûreté c'est un
problème d'exploitation
après quand mélenchon dit que le
nucléaire n'est pas sûr il contredit des
études qui sont pliées par les médecins
eux-mêmes disant que quand on compare
les inconvénients de toutes les formes
de production électrique est bien le
nucléaire s'avère être la plus sûre
d'entre elles accident compris voilà
donc il faut aller voir ce que racontent
les médecins et j'ai plutôt envie de
faire confiance aux études qui sont
publiés dans les revues médicales à
comité de lecture qui avec monsieur
mélenchon quand il s'agit d'avoir un
avis là dessus et tout à l'heure à 15h
30m et il avait de bonnes va annoncer
son plan de sobriété c'est un mot que
vous utilisez depuis longtemps le mot
sobriété jean marc jancovici est ce que
comme a laissé entendre pour l'instant
emmanuel macron laisser le chauffage à
19 et baissé la clim c'est ça la
sobriété alors pour faire le lien entre
les deux questions je vais préciser une
chose importante c'est pas parce que je
considère qu'il ya des affirmations sur
la dangerosité du nucléaire qui sont
infondées que je mets dans le nucléaire
la totalité des marges de manoeuvre qui
sont à notre disposition pour faire face
soit aux questions de pénuries d'énergie
fossile soit aux questions de
réchauffement climatique je ne les ai
jamais dit et je ne le dirai jamais donc
il suffit de lire ce que j'écris pour
comprendre que je dit deux choses je dis
1 le nucléaire n'est pas l'horreur en ce
qui concerne la sûreté c'est pas le truc
qui va tuer tout le monde higuain mais
pour autant il suffit pas de compter sur
le nucléaire pour se débarrasser de tous
les problèmes que nous avons devant nous
et en particulier la première marche de
manoeuvre qui va falloir mettre en
oeuvre en ce qui concerne le défi
énergétique et climatique c'est
effectivement ce qu'on appelle la
sobriété à la sobriété c'est quoi c'est
délibérément et de façon organisée
baisser la quantité d'énergie qu'on
utilise en bc l'énergie ça veut dire
baisser le parc de machines qu'on
utilise parce qu'en fait l'énergie pour
vous qui buvait le pétrole et vous
mettez pas au doigt dans les prises
enfin je vous déconseille donc ce qu'ils
causent quand ça veut dire utiliser
moins renoncé ça veut dire baisser les
flux physiques qui sont à notre
disposition donc ça veut dire avoir des
voitures qui se déplacent qui sont plus
petites qui sont moins nombreuses et qui
sont pas motorisées de la même manière
ferme en trajet donc on avoir moins pas
nécessairement ferment un trajet mais
les faire moins long et avec des modes -
mécanisée on va dire ça veut dire que la
quantité d'objets qu'on peut s'acheter
va baisser ça veut dire etc c'est ce
genre de choses c'est ça que ça veut
dire la sobriété et il faut l'organiser
de telle sorte qu'on soit pas trop
malheureux
dans ce genre d'évolution global
voilà ce que c'est dans mon esprit dont
je reviens à ma question quand emmanuel
macron dit nous allons devoir faire face
à la sobriété et dans la même phrase dit
qu'il faut laisser le chauffage à 19 et
baissé la clim est ce que ça suffit non
ça suffira pas en fait l'énergie
abondante est ce qui a fait la
croissance économique des deux derniers
siècles l'industrialisation la
mondialisation l'urbanisation
l'augmentation du temps libre le fait
qu'on ait des études longues et des
retraites les 35 heures les six semaines
de congés payés la tertiarisation des
hongrois et oui ça fait beaucoup
d'où j'en reviens à ce que j'ai tout à
l'heure sur le fait que votre profession
a eu un peu de mal à comprendre tout ça
il ya toujours un peu de mal à
comprendre tout ça j'aimais bien quand
même bien trouver des coupables je
n'aime pas
qui vous est souvent donné la parole
souvent deux fois mais d'anciens cette
émission j'ai eu du temps soyons précis
donc je suis pas en train de vous faire
un reproche à vous en particulier je
suis en train d'essayer d'expliquer
pourquoi il ya des gens qui aujourd'hui
sont surpris en disant ah on a tous ces
problèmes là sur les bras on n'en avait
pas conscience bah je suis juste en
train d'identifier la cause la cause
c'est qu'on n'entend pas souvent parler
donc je reviens à ce que j'aime et c'est
normal c'est difficile à raccrocher à
l'actualité sauf quand les prix
s'envolent ou qui a eu bien même ne
sentais pas de manière palpable cette
limite que l'on découvre aujourd'hui là
je suis la pénurie la question de la
ligne je suis là sur la menace du black
out oui je suis d'accord il ya une autre
raison c'est que le monde économique ne
fait pas le lien cercle monde économique
considère que toute l'information est
dans les prix et qu'il n'y a pas de
problème avec les prix y aura pas de
problème sur la disponibilité physique à
l'avenir malheureusement c'est pas vrai
donc pour en revenir à la question de la
sobriété la sobriété ça va donc porter
sur tous les sujets que j'évoque là
quand on commence à rentrer dans
l'organisation de la sobriété on doit
également rentrer dans l'aménagement du
territoire la façon dont les gens se
déplacent l'espace habitable les métiers
qu'on va faire la longueur de nos études
la nature de nos études on va rentrer et
gratuit ça veut dire rationnés ça veut
dire décider de ce qu'on a droit de
faire ou de ne pas faire ça peut poser
des limites c'est déjà le cas vous est
rationnée en nombre de meurtres par
exemple nombre de meurtres auxquels vous
avez droit directement via la zéro donc
le rationnement est déjà quelque chose
qui existe dans organisation de la
société il ya des choses auxquelles vous
êtes aussi important pardon mais encore
une fois vous avez parlé du jeu vous
dire les ans je préfère juste concentré
après si pour vous le fait de laisser
les français
consommer largement et librement de dd
des matières qui peuvent abîmer à terme
la planète est ce que pour vous c'est
une forme de crime ah non c'est pas une
forme de crime mais c'est un arbitrage
c'est à dire que c'est un arbitrage au
profit du présent et au détriment de
l'avenir donc c'est un arbitrage que je
veux dire autrement qui profite aux
rumeurs et aux vieux et au détriment des
jeunes je vais donc je suis capable de
m'incriminer aussi puisque je fais
partie de la première catégorie et jean
marc jacot complice ça veut dire
qu'aujourd'hui si vous étiez aux
manettes vous diriez il faut il faut
rationner les chronos de ré il faut dire
bah voilà par habitant et le rail ans il
ya deux manières il ya deux manières de
mettre en place des limites de toujours
eu historiquement de la ja par les
quantités par les prix donc une manière
de rationner l'énergie entre guillemets
c'est à dire de limiter la consommation
d'énergie est par exemple de monter son
prix délibérément c'est tout le débat
sur la fiscalité de l'énergie et puis
vous avez une deuxième manière qui est
de limiter les quantités or par exemple
sur les kilométreurs auxquelles vous
avez droit quand vous êtes en voiture on
limite par les quantités ont dit pas
plus vous payez cher que vous avez de
rendre les vite on dit une limite à ne
pas dépasser 80 ou 90 route 130 sur
autoroute lieu de dire il faut laisser
le chauffage à 19 et baissé la cleave
vous estimer qu emmanuel macron aurait
dû dire bah écoutez on va pendant un an
cependant on va carrément limiter la
vitesse sandra alors oui moi je suis
favorable par exemple à ce qu'on baisse
la ligne et la vitesse limite sur
autoroute je pense que ça fait partie
des mesures qu'on devrait compter va
prendre non mais par exemple si on passe
mais salle électrique si on fait sous ce
jeu plus quand même là même sûr que
c'est ainsi qui n'arrivera pas demain
matin et je ne sais même pas s'il
arrivera un jour vous avez aujourd'hui
40 millions de véhicules particuliers en
france vous avez 1,2 milliard de
voitures dans le monde les constructeurs
sont mondiaux donc ils vont pas passer à
l'électrique juste pour la france et
quand vous regardez la quantité de
matériaux qu'il faudrait pour avoir un
parc électrique de voitures dans le
monde avec toujours des voitures d'une
tonne ou d'une tonne et demie qui
roulerait à l'électricité qu'on regarde
et la quantité de matériaux sur la
patrie la solution fou je suis con va
pas y arriver c'est à dire qu'il ya des
limites physiques aussi sur la quantité
de métal disponible sur terre sur la
vitesse à laquelle on peut ouvrir les
mines sur la vitesse à laquelle
il ya interdit les voitures thermiques
qui d'ailleurs n'est pas du tout prêt
pour la voiture électrique une très
bonne voiture électrique qui s'appelle
la voiture électrique partager ou qui
s'appelle le vélo électrique donc c'est
ce que je disais tout à l'heure on va
pas qu'à garder 40 millions de véhicules
particuliers pesant une tonne ou de
tonnes dans un monde sera vendu faut se
limiter donc ça on va devoir s'organiser
avec moins est ce que ça sera un drame
pas nécessairement mais par contre ce
qui est sûr c'est que si ça nous tombe
dessus sans qu'on l'ait organisé l'asa
sera désagréable d'appeler à une forme
de planification et d'anticipation c'est
aussi ce que il avait deux bornes
propose cet après-midi puisqu'elle va
proposer un certain plan que la ville de
paris par exemple hier annonce que les
monuments les musées municipaux vont
éteindre à 22 heures que la tour eiffel
va éteindre à 23h45 que les bâtiments
publics seront moins chauffer ya quand
même aussi une question sociale est ce
qu'on va pas se retrouver avec les plus
modestes qui vont avoir froid aussi
parce que tout simplement ils n'auront
pas les moyens de payer et les plus
riches qui vont quand même continuer à
prendre leur jet alors si on limite par
les prix c'est ce qui se passe est du
reste on le voit bien avec le débat qui
en ce moment sur le bouclier tarifaire
sur l'électricité ou sur le gaz
c'est tout le débat à partir du moment
où on laisse les prix augmenter de
manière très forte ça revient à dire ça
revient à dire que c'est un effort qui
va proportionnellement est plus
difficile à supporter pour les gens
modestes si on limite par les quantités
on n'a pas ce problème je vais prendre
un exemple récent au moment du co lead
on a limité les déplacements par les
quantités qu'on a dit rich ou pour voir
naître chez vous vous avez droit de
sortir une heure par jour bon ça c'est
quelque chose qui en fait plus équitable
dans le principe c'est à dire que la
limite qu'on vous impose dépend moins de
vos revenus et qu' elle s'impose à tous
que vous riche ou pauvre et qu'elle
s'impose à tous je suis personnellement
plus partisan de ce genre de mesure je
les trouve plus équitable et plus
sociale dont quand on peut limiter par
les quantités c'est mieux mais vous
disiez de force et internationale il ya
quand même une question qui se pose
aussi c'est que là pendant que nous on
va laisser le chauffage sur 19 qu'on va
comme le demande par exemple à mini de
la transition énergétique interdire les
climats avec la porte ouverte on va
aussi envoyer nos footballeurs au qatar
dans des stades à ciel ouvert climatisé
oui est ce qu'on n'est pas en train se
donnait du mal pour rien non alors
d'abord ces deux problèmes très
distincts le fait d'envoyer les
footballeurs au qatar ça dépend des gens
qui envoient les footballeurs au qatar
c'est eux qu'il faut poser la question
de savoir ce qu'ils considèrent que ces
quelques chemises sur l'impératif de
notre geste serre qui sont coincés en ce
qui nous concerne
l'approvisionnement en pétrole de
l'europe est déjà en train de décliner
pour des raisons géologiques c'est à
dire la quantité de pétrole qu'on peut
importer en europe est en train de
baisser de façon structurelle tout
simplement parce que les gisements
pétroliers s'épuise dans le monde et
c'est quelque chose qui va continuer à
l'avenir les 16 premiers fournisseurs de
l'europe devraient voir leur production
diviser par deux d'ici à 2050 ce qui
veut dire que la quantité de pétrole
qu'on va pouvoir importer en europe va
baisser d'un facteur 2 à 10 d'ici à 2050
toutes façons et faire faire des
économies c'est pareil pour le gaz le
pic de production mondiale du gaz c'est
aux alentours de 2030 donc de toutes
façons poutine ou pas poutine il va
falloir que on remplace les chaudières à
gaz il va falloir qu'on on est une
industrie qui tourne avec moins de gaz
et qu'on arrête de produire de
l'électricité au gaz poutine ou pas
poutine donc de toutes façons ces gestes
là l'organisation de la société en
fonction il va falloir le faire et pour
savoir ce qu'il est pertinent de faire
en premier il faut compter ça si vous
devez 1 milliard d'euros à votre
banquier le fait que vous fassiez une
économie sur le kinder bueno ça va pas
changer grand chose donc il faut compter
et aujourd'hui le fait de compter les
consommations d'énergie de les
hiérarchiser de etc c'est quelque chose
qui est très peu présent dans l'esprit
des gestionnaires tout simplement parce
que l'énergie coûte pas très cher on
s'en est pas beaucoup occupé et donc on
a fait beaucoup de gâchis est ce que
cette question aussi de la décroissance
puisque vous le disiez au fond dit en
fait cette énergie que l'on a développé
c'est ce qui a permis vous lisiez les 35
heures le tout en fait finalement notre
vie entière repose sur cette
consommation d'énergie et si on étend la
lumière au fond tout ça s'écroule est ce
qu'il faut en passer par une
décroissance maîtrisé est ce que c'est
ça la solution c'est à dire accepter qu
aura pas cette croissance infinie alors
il faut d'autant plus l'accepter que
c'est ce qu'il va se passer quoi qu'il
arrive quoi qu'il arrive ils n'ont donc
autant la compagnie quoi donc de toute
façon il va falloir le penser en gros il
ya quelque chose que je dis aujourd'hui
souvent à mes étudiants c'est
tout ce que vous allez imaginer comme
solution il faut que ça passe la rampe
dans un monde en décroissance c'est pas
sûr qu'on va la voir le monde en est
conscient je vous demande même pas de le
souhaiter c'est pas le sujet par contre
il faut être sûr que les solutions qu'on
imagine n'ont pas besoin impérativement
de la croissance pour être opérationnel
parce que si c'est le cas on prend un
risque extrêmement fort et on prend le
risque évidemment que ça ne se passe pas
comme prévu je vais prendre un exemple
on parle en ce moment des retraites il
ya quelques années j'avais regardé les
prévisions de croissance du conseil
d'orientation des retraites pour décider
des cotisations d'ici à 2050 est
l'hypothèse la pire c'était que la
croissance n'était que de 1 ou à et 10%
par an alors que bien évidemment d'ici à
2050 fait désolé d'annoncer sa mort fin
je les ai déjà dit souvent le monde va
pas rester en croissance il va passer en
récession structurelles récession
structurelles on voit l'allemagne par
exemple annoncé j'ai laquelle passe en
récession alors que bruno le maire
culturel dis lui que la france va
continuer une perspective de croissance
y compris potentiellement de 2,7 à ce
qu'il est prêt à engager toutes ses
économies personnelles sur ce pronostic
d'ici à ce qu'il cesse ces fonds qui
avaient l'air de douter de vous dire
qu'il ya une forme de méthode coué bah
évidemment mais il est payé pour ça donc
ce que je dit juste c'est que en fait
après que l'abondance énergétique
c'est-à-dire l'abondance des machines
qui produisent pour nous aujourd'hui et
permis à la production d'augmenter sans
cesse la contraction énergétique va
contracter de manière structurelle le
parc de machines année après année et
donc ça va contracter la production est
économiquement ça s'appelle une
récession structurelles alors ça va pas
être tous les ans nécessairement un an
ya de la croissance un manga de l'airé
gestion etc mais malheureusement c'est
essentiellement de son jeu dans ce genre
de paysage qui va falloir apprendre à
vivre ensemble c'est très très différent
du paysage dans lequel nous avons vécu
jusqu'à maintenant et donc ce qui fera
la différence et de l'avoir anticipée
jean marc jancovici
c'est vrai d'un trou d'interview que
vous êtes
sur la défensive c'est le moins qu'on ne
suis pas sur la défensive mais je de
temps en temps j'essaye de encore une
fois d'être un peu direct parce qu'on
n'a pas beaucoup de temps mais parce que
vous êtes aussi les cassandres jean marc
jancovici ingénieur président du shift
project et auteur de ce best-seller un
monde sans fin qui a passionné qui
passionne encore les français il à 8h53
sur rmc bfm tv
merci à pauline de manière dans quelques
instants on fait un point sur incendie
de saumos sont en gironde ça continue la
veuve d'un terroriste du bataclan
rapatrie en france un point rmc on y
revient en quelques secondes et puis le
plan du gouvernement pour l'énergie
comment va-t-on passé l'hiver à tout de
suite
[Musique]
sur les voitures pas mal non plus la
vôtre
sévère
et bien non il a raison c'est vers abri
[Musique]
et hulu
ocz aider
nouvelle kia traçant des 139 euros par
mois pour conditions de reprise qui les
a plus de 89 ans y avait entendu en
électrique pourquoi pas vous
[Musique]
j'ai eu avec la drève
expérience dans ce
combat
la première
là